Federal authorities have initiated a multi-state manhunt for William Butcher
If anyone spots William Butcher or any of his known associates. Marvin Milk, Hugh Campbell or this man.
Please call 1 888 Zero Crime
The world still needs superheroes
So let's get out there, and let's take them down
We are famous now!
Don't you worry,
daddy's home
Ain't you lucky that I showed up.
You guys ready?
rousing music
Haaans Zimmmmer
Title card!
Cut to black!
That is amazing!
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie!
We got a brand-new trailer for the boys season
2 there's a whole bunch of footage.
So we'll break it all down there's a bunch
of Easter eggs.
If you're brand new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos will do
a new Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be subscriber and let me know what
your most hyped up about for the boys season
two the season is dropping September 4, but
remember there dropping episodes weekly this
season and there's a short movie, the boys
made a short movie that the gonna release
after the season is done all explained the
end of the video, but because they are dropping
episodes weekly.
I will be doing weekly Easter egg videos for
all the episodes is all explained that we
get closer the season.
W Way more trailers before that happens to
but the whole theme of this trailer is Homelander
in the seven declaring open war on butcher
in the boys in the wake of the events of season
one QE kill translucent they want to get back
for that then Butcher sent Homelander that
message were coming for you quote of quote
packed up with his remains buried at the bottom
of the ocean so that the deep would find it
and deliver it to Homelander for them that
was basically them throwing the gauntlet then
then finding out that starlight was going
out with Hughie so Homelander has been watching
starlight so she really has to play it safe
during season 2, so that he doesn't suspect
that she's really a boys plant, but it wasn't
clear.
She is still with Hughie she is still working
with the boys informing on what the seven
is doing in their big plans swami see all
this footage picks up after a big time jump
at the end of season one when Homelander took
butcher to his ex-wife's house to meet his
son and see that she was still alive and hadn't
contacted him in the five years that he believed
that she was dead or missing.
So if there's a big manhunt for butcher in
this trailer as they say on the news at some
point after this moment of the end of season
one.
It means he escapes from Homelander in the
sheer fact that there needs to be a big manhunt
for him means that Homelander can't find him
either with all of his powers.
There's some footage later of black noir watching
footage of butcher in the boys like at some
point black noir get set on them in the reason
why that's even bigger threat now is because
that opening scene from season to to little
while ago I posted that scene to my channel
so a link at the end of this is the opening
scene from season 2 episode one is Giancarlo
Esposito's character negotiating with the
government Jim Beaver's character here getting
supers in the military.
What's the terms of the contract going to
be wall black noir is busy taking down the
super villain that Homelander help create
last season.
The whole reason they convinced the military
to say yes to letting supers in the chain
of command.
Contracts in the field to watch crazy sandwich
when they're in actual combat whom exactly
are your heroes report members is always placing
chickens want to rest subheadings.
So the whole set up here is to let you know
how powerful black noir is into be a kind
of a funny moment like what is going on with
this bunny in that little kid.
Obviously that's a reference to what he does
in the comics in his comic book character.
If you feel like a lot of the stuff in the
scenes in this trailer are hard-core, the
stuff in the boys comic book that they don't
do is way more , but the thing they don't
tell you during the boys season one, at least
explicitly is just because some of the superheroes
and super villains have God tier powers doesn't
mean that they're good at using them.
So even though Homelander has all these abilities
doesn't mean that he could find butcher in
the boys on the spot.
It also lets you know how good butcher in
the boys are in hiding out butcher himself
is a master at manipulating people usually
finds out what their weaknesses are in then
uses those against them, but some of the links
that he goes to with some of the methods that
he uses are just as bad is what Homelander
does.
So this one of the messages of the boys series
is that everybody is kind of terrible on both
sides.
Everybody's doing really bad stuff, but the
reason why it's so hard for the seven to find
the boys why they need his big manhunt is
that most the superhero teams like the seven
and Stormfront's old team payback which is
a big Marvel Avengers Easter egg or actually
terrible at being superheroes because they're
bad people.
Because a lot of them are bad people, but
because they're bad at coordinating all their
powers in a fight and a lot of them don't
even know how to fully use their abilities
like Homelander knows about most of his abilities.
He does know how to use several different
abilities all the same time.
This is big scene of the seven and a rally
there some protesters with signs about a superhero
arms race.
This is all the continuation of that superhero
military plot line from last week.
It was the other trailer where Stormfront
is meeting Homelander for the first time while
there filming a commercial for this was other
than trying to get the public excited about
superheroes in the military than Homelander
just turns and pops this military that that's
giving him the bird like a balloon like it's
no big deal.
The funny way they cut this trailer to is
a Homelander's having this meeting with the
rest the seven saying let's take them down,
but the way they cut it makes it seem like
he's talking about butcher in the boys when
he might just be talking about the fake super
villains out there that he himself helped
create, but this takes the rent of super villains
around the world.
So just as you know that every member of the
seven is an in on the secret and what's really
going on behind the scenes black noir clearly
knows what's going on because it his mission
to take down this guy the opening scene from
season 2 episode one.
But if it wasn't clear in terms of who has
abilities around the world.
Where do superheroes come from from international
countries outside the US.
The whole thing within the comic book world
of the boys is that Vought American are the
only people who can manufacture compound be
there are no naturally born superheroes other
than the one that was born from Homelander
here his son.
That's a big revelation, but here about a
big superhero from state like China or Japan
or India or some international country is
because Vought gave them compound V everybody
gets their powers for the most part from compound
be so there's suddenly a bunch of super villains
popping up in the international country.
The secret is is that they came from Vought.
You also see Giancarlo Esposito's character
at their meeting here.
He was Stillwell's boss last season.
Now he just taking over management duties
now they're going to be in the military like
that opening scene where he's talking to Jim
Beaver's character.
The funny thing about him to in real life
that he just blowing up big time.
Obviously he was amazing during Breaking Bad
and better call Saul, but he's also the main
villain on the Mandalorian right now to be
really big during the Mandalorian season 2
just coming out right after the boys season
two episodes air of your big fan of him you
can see a bunch of him later this year his
big storyline now is getting supers in the
military.
But then also getting them in the White House
in which is basically a metaphor for getting
superheroes to take over the government eventually.
That's much bigger plot within the boys comic
book so they might cover that in future seasons.
This season is all about continuing that military
plot line bringing Stormfront onto the team
and dealing with the retaliation from the
seven against the boys all of the boys freaking
out about being famous on television like
holy crap, the world is after us now, but
this is also kind of cool.
There's a bunch of footage of butcher coming
back just tearing through a bunch of superheroes
and regular people kicking everyone's butts
the line about daddy's home is probably a
reference to him returning after being on
the DL escaping from Homelander like he really
has to go off the grid so that Homelander
can find them.
The whole thing with the boys short movie
that they just announced for season 2 is
it is good to be all about butcher and what
he was doing between the events of season
one in season 2 of this is there was a bunch
of extra stuff for his storyline that they
shot for season to that they didn't have room
for in the actual episodes of the straight
up just turned it into a separate movie that
can air after the boys season 2 finale drops,
I'm assuming just the week after that the
will happen is, is when they start airing
episodes and I start doing Easter egg videos
always remind people about that short movie
just think of it is a really cool bonus content
hopefully they'll do that in future seasons
because it does take them a while to make
new episode.
So just something cool to sort of tide you
over some extra content.
I really love the footage of Homelander trying
to teach his son how to fly by just pushing
him off the roof of butcher's wife sows like
their young kid let 'er rip classic 80s dad
move like teaching your son how to swim by
just pushing him in the pool letting them
flop around almost drowned.
There has been a ton more footage of Homelander
with his son, but obviously this takes place
relatively soon after the events of the end
of season one, we don't know exactly when
this happens during the episodes.
I'm really glad to get confirmation that Stormfront
has all of her comic book superpowers to they
implied during the lifestream that they did
while ago that you got some psychic abilities
and she some sort of social media maven, but
didn't say a lot about her comic book abilities
this trailer just clarify some of that.
There's a couple cool fight scenes that she
has during this to using her powers.
If you haven't read the boys comic book Stormfront
is meant to be a parody of shazam it DC, but
also Thor at Marvel to she can flashiest lightning
based abilities.
She's also superstrong in the comics.
I don't if she has super strength in the TV
show to I'm assuming she is at least a little
bit of super strength.
I think she's basically supposed to be a foil
for Homelander this season.
There were a bunch of other big trailers and
some big news the drop in the Marvel, DC world,
so I'll try to do videos for everything in
post all your big questions in the comments
below will try to address that in my future
boys videos, but like I said that the more
trailers and promos that they'll drop for
this before the season starts in September
everyone click here for that other brand-new
footage from the boys season 2 and click
here for that.
Deleted scene of Michael Keaton's Batman from
crisis on infinite earths.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe I'll see you guys tonight!